hey youtubers is charlie so
international wonder woman trailer
little bit of new footage of the fight
scenes and we learned a little bit about
the villains too so i'll be mostly
talking about that yeah chick dollar
bill atiba gotcha Star Wars manana
Hannah nice toy atiba technique act
emotion you viola a car show two edges
owe me any abou lotsa easy of Stella
she's annoyed
[Music]
yes you being a puzzler
he needs a beautiful
yeah at the candy secret are Steve Ott
Rivera Stowe's notchet secret edoku Don
Scott Yellowstone Scalia marco de oro de
Montes eggettes aaron doh hongyun drive
it is Donovan Bosley was later watching
Rockets so slightly longer fight
sequences just some more shiny I can't
wait to see her in Justice League like
you look at her costume here and like
they showed off a little bit better in
this version of the trailer just
super-bright super-bright nice saturated
colors it hasn't been faded by time when
you get to Batman V Superman like they
took a lot of color out of that film so
maybe it's brighter and we just couldn't
tell but it looks like she just has it
polished it in a while so I think you
know by the time we get to that moment
in Justice League where they're all
assembled Superman's back in that like
the shinier version of his costume we'll
see her in a shinier version of her
Wonder Woman uniform in this right here
like this art that they released back
during comic-con is just an
approximation is this like a photoshop
job that won't be exactly how they look
but it's pretty close but back to the
Wonder Woman movie so one of the
important things that we haven't talked
a lot about is the villains of the movie
like everybody knows that Ares is
typically wonder woman's biggest villain
but it looks like they're starting in a
relatively real world place even though
they kind of teased her backstory when
she's explaining her backstory to Chris
Pine saying she's the daughter of Zeus
and Hippolyta this is Hippolytus so the
movie has to do a lot of the same things
that that first Thor movie did where
they have to reconcile how they fit the
gods into modern mythology like are they
actual gods or are they just like alien
beings metahumans who are super powerful
and seem like gods like how's this gonna
work because Wonder Woman in the comics
is an actual demi got like in the most
current version of her backstory it's
been reckoned a couple times but in the
most current version she is the daughter
of Zeus and Apollo too she is half God
so that seems like the version the
movies going with so like you know she
can't fly but she has super strength
she's almost as powerful as Superman as
long as he hasn't been sunbathing for
too long but in Batman V Superman she's
on the list of metahumans so I think
she's closer to being a metahuman than
she is to being an actual demigod so
we'll see how they explained the zoo's
part of this he's
really like the hardest part to explain
because the Amazons could just be
metahumans but Danny Huston is playing
the big villain this is World War one so
these are not Nazis the Nazis didn't
come around till World War two one of
the reasons I think they put it during
World War one is just to differentiate
it from that first captain america movie
so you have Danny Huston who looks like
he's a high-ranking member of the German
military then you have this other female
character here who is definitely playing
a villain but they've been very
mysterious about who she's actually
playing so she is playing someone from
the comics but I think what they're
doing is is it's dr. poison and she's
working for Danny Huston like think
about the technology they had around
world war one weapons of mass
destruction they hadn't got to the atom
bomb yet but when you talk about Ares
God of War God of devastation like the
other villains of the Wonder Woman
comics they try to create as much death
and chaos as possible what's more deadly
and insidious than creating toxic gas so
it just seems a little more plausible
that that would be happening around
world war one so it allows them to do
doctor poison or at least a version of
the character there have been a couple
different versions of him in the comics
and he's typically a male character but
there was a gender flip version of the
character called granddaughter who had
history with the Amazons like her own
grandmother had battled with ippoliti so
I think that's who this character is but
as you can imagine all the incarnations
try to create a version of poison to
poison the heroes so that just feels
like a very world war one you know
mustard gas type situation whereby she
is working with these Germans to try and
create some very deadly weapon that
Wonder Woman has to stop but as for
Cersei like the other pantheon of Wonder
Woman villains Ares I think that they'll
all show up eventually like there will
be Wonder Woman sequels so just like the
Justice League movie isn't going
straight to Darkseid I don't think the
Wonder Woman movie is going to go
straight to Ares like it's going to
start in a relatively real world place
like the other reason I think they said
it during world war one is just because
it'd be around a hundred years before
Batman V Superman happen and that's what
they want to say like Wonder Woman at
the end of World War One just bailed and
went and hid out for a hundred years so
whatever it is she
tries to do she saves the day but only a
great cost and it causes her to lay down
the shield until Batman V Superman comes
along which means if they do a Wonder
Woman sequel then it'll probably be set
in present-day like the captain america
movies did so like you do the first
captain america movie in the past to the
origins of the character then he gets
thrust into modern day just like Wonder
Woman has been thrust back into the
public spotlight and then each movie
thereafter is set during present day so
if you heard that this Wonder Woman
movie takes place during two different
time periods the distant past in the
present that's why because she's so
long-lived you have to tell that old
story before you can start telling all
the new stuff but the other really cool
thing is that the Amazons were part of
the first big battle with the forces of
Darkseid and apocalypse there's a mother
box in the Justice League trailer the
Amazons were there for that they were
part of that but they'll explain that
during the Justice League movie next
year so we'll get like a good picture of
Amazon history during the Wonder Woman
movie with maybe a couple teasers for
justice league dark side backstory but
most of Earth's history with apocalypse
in the new gods will be spelled out
during the Justice League movie so let
me know what you guys are most excited
for in the Wonder Woman move I love her
soundtrack she has one of the best
soundtracks of all the characters in
this new DC Universe like of all the
things that Zack Snyder did with the new
characters I feel like Batman moves
really well Wonder Woman moves really
well to like the way they shoot her
action the way she dances around the
battlefield so just to be clear though
Zack Snyder didn't have anything to do
with the Wonder Woman movie that's all
geoff johns and Patty Jenkins like Geoff
Johns co-wrote the script for Wonder
Woman so it's like the first Geoff Johns
DC movie in this new DC Universe so just
get hype about that it's really like the
beginning of the Geoff Johns era of DC
movies but if you guys didn't know
there's a DC giveaway going on right now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video tomorrow we have superman and
supergirl vs. metal oh so i'll post that
video after it airs but we have Jessie
quake on the flash on Tuesday Wednesday
is like a SummerSlam rematch between
Stardust and Stephen Amell although
technically he can't use the Stardust
name anymore and then on Thursday is
justice society so like a big week for
DC TV but there's also some cool
ghostrider stuff so I'm going to be
doing a Marvel video later tonight so
I'll explain all that stuff in that
video what you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for that Jessie
quick flash trailer and you can click
here for that arrow SummerSlam trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight